歡迎回來趙華
歡迎說
我想要請教艾倫
你有一段時間有存高息ETF
跟你形象沒有很搭軋
其實我內心是保守的
也對啦
到現在也有
你的外在是奔放的
內心是保守的
是這樣子
外在是用動能
內心是用高息
對對對
那你還有高息ETF嗎
有啊
真的假啊
還要申報
還要申報什麼
對啊
分析師要申報
還要申報
你不是很早之前就買了嗎
到現在還是有啦
就是讓他每個月扣款
確實這一波上半年
那個高息有
股價有動起來
就發現難得有跟上
整個行情的節奏
可是在去年他的表現
是不如大盤的情況下
你不會想要放棄嗎
不會啊
因為他也只是我一小部分的投資
對
其他就積極一點
他是你的一小部分
可是可能對今天的來賓來說
是他長年很大的一個部位
不只高息ETF
還有像高息的股票
去年真的悶爆了
今年現在揚眉吐氣
我們剛剛在跟他討論的時候
都要教他一聲師傅
接下來買什麼
我們先來歡迎他
就是我們的存股總編傅旭哥
嗨 湛華 艾倫你們好
觀眾朋友大家好
傅旭哥好
還記得去年傅旭哥上節目的時候
有一段時間也很坦白的說
績效數大判
而且去年其實沒有賺到太多錢
沒有 我去年還虧錢
我去年的績效是-6.1
大盤是漲了27%
我去年其實
台股資產是縮水的
沒有賺錢
台股資產縮水
但是我們先來介紹一下
我們的存股從編傅虛哥
他很喜歡做產業調查
其實我好佩服傅虛哥
當年在航運三雄的時候
傅虛哥把他的現金流
未來的運力都算得清清楚楚
基本面分析做得非常紮實
存股年齡百萬這個客氣了
去年其實股息快要200萬
對快要200萬
190幾萬
對嘛
所以縮水還好啊
有股息啊
對對對
去年是雖然資產縮水
但是股息又創了個人新高
我幾乎每年領的股息
都一直在創新高
是
朱宥明
別把運氣當實力
要懂得等
要見好就收
對
尤其在股市多頭的時候
我常常就把這句話
三不五十再附送一次
那我們先來講近期的狀況
因為今年
剛剛也跟艾倫聊了
去年苦哈哈的高息
但今年高息因為像什麼聯發科
都來了
瑞育聯勇 聯電
大家都來了
所以有沒有機會複製
像2023年席差雙轉的一年
的確是已經在複製了
今年的高股息ETF
大概報酬率
而且才半年而已
都是40 50%
跟2023年有的比了
而且今年才過一半
搞不好下半年不知道會怎麼演
我們不知道
那我個人
我先講我個人的狀況
剛好這個
整個上半年也快結束了
剛好做一個檢討總結
那我今年 去年雖然是-6.1
但是我今年上半年
統計到大概是昨天為止
我的台股
熱騰騰的
台股資產
大概韓習的報酬率是33.2
那總金額就是跟去年底比較
我的台股資產
增加超過700萬以上
我目前的所謂的蝌蚪頭的股票
對 五檔是蝌蚪頭
他就佔我現在部位70%
那五檔蝌蚪頭 今年的表現都相當不錯
群抑震 我目前持股比重將近四分之一
今年以來漲了66%
而且還沒有除全息
他還沒有除全息
那新產已經除了
那韓息加進去是將近30%的報酬率
他佔我大概是15.7%
那第三個
長榮本來沒那麼多 長榮本來就有7%
是最近長榮出息之後暴跌
我買的比較多
對 我在他大概190以下
我是買蠻多的
但是傑敏KY目前是我第四大持股
本來他是第三大
他的比重本來跟現在的長榮差不多
只是傑敏KY今年漲了133.3%
公佈員縣超起來 我的成本大概
我是從80幾塊一直買到大概110
那我的成本大概是90幾那邊
那大概就是又已經除息了
他一天就填息了
對 現在正好
所以我的獲利大概有一倍以上
一倍 那我就最近減碼的比較多
蛤 罵掉他了
我減了三分之一
所以導致現在的比重大概是7.8
那我第五高的是地寶
地保比較沒有表現
這三年 去年表現很不好
去年跌了40幾%
那今年還是
雖然沒跌那麼深
但是還是沒有起盛
但是我地保去年的時候
我地保去年是第一大持股
那我減很多
而且是虧虧
我在節目有分享
大概虧了150萬以上
從60張一直減到現在
十幾張
但是15-16張還是佔7點多
現在是地保
整個起來看起來是還不錯
有33.2%報酬率
我都還記得富巨哥有分享地保的時候
就是因為要停損
然後他的產業前景出現了一些變化
對 很痛欸
一下子就虧了
就是停損150幾萬
但是做股票這個你一定要適應
你不可能
你一定會有時候會看左眼
有時候運氣不好
那你不要就卡在那邊
很多人就是我操勞了
我就一直卡在那邊
你動彈不得
那你這個路沒辦法走下去
你一定要譬如說要認錯
要調整一定要走
這個痛一定要痛一次
你要當成家產便飯
好 那現在已經創新高了
對不對 現在算是妥妥的多頭吧
那這兩天是有比較急速的一些修正
你會覺得是真的有風險了
還是建好就說時候到了
還是還會再創高對 雖然我今年報酬率是不錯但是我反而會越來越小心然後我難免會把一些台股現在的風險有稍微放大
我覺得做投資就是要這樣
就是說你這個就是要
要對短期悲觀
但是要對長期樂觀
我一直都是這樣
那現在台股有什麼樣的風險
我比較在意的有三個
第一個就是估值太高了
現在台股的本益比大概是31倍
可是我們獲利有在提升
有 但是你假如跟全球比較
這個資料我做得很辛苦
也感謝財經M平方跟StarQ
謝謝他們 我們的好朋友
M平方
現在台股的本益比已經跟美股差不多了
有嗎 有這麼誇張嗎
S&P500的本利比是32倍
我們是31.8
差不多
但是其他國家
譬如說歐洲大概是16 7倍
那比較那個
像巴西 中國
也不過13倍嘛
日韓都還低
都比日韓高
日韓大概是20倍 23倍
我比較好奇的是
韓國只有23倍
韓國有那麼便宜嗎 福祉哥
對啊
韓國它本來本利比你知道嗎
他長期歷史的本利比都在11到12倍而已
算三倍了
其實他這次漲好幾倍
還23倍
其實對他以前的韓國老股民而言
這個算很高了
對
我為什麼覺得這個有風險呢
是因為
你會覺得台股合理的
台灣是AI這個浪潮
最大的受惠的股市
我們GDP成長20%
對
但是問題是說
我認為這個整個
我也肯定AI帶來的商機
但是你假如
去深入了解這個AI產業鏈
你會發覺全世界最棒的AI公司
其實都在美國
對啦
那AI這個產業鏈的
大部分的附加價值啦
我也覺得都是在美國
台灣是有分一杯羹
但是絕對沒有分的美國多
我們有台積電
但是除了台積電之外
可能比較難找到
所以你說台灣的本益比
直比美國我就覺得有一點違和感
那第二個風險就是
槓桿
偏高
有一點高啦
真的最近都在聊這個
對 然後這個
榮志瑜大概逼近6000億
我認為6000億
對照現在的股市量仍是還好
還好
對還好
我認為以現在的股市
還可以接受
問題是說這個
券商不限用途借貸
5月底金管會的統計是
1兆2500億
所以你加起來是1.8兆
你要這樣算
這還有借房貸 用信貸
這個還沒統計進去
所以我估計這個大概
整個散戶借貸
這個都是散戶的借錢
法人不太做融資
他們是從銀行搬錢來的
這只有散戶
散戶大概借貸的金額
槓桿大概是2兆元
那2兆元大概
出股可以做4兆元的股票
對不對
融資率大概50到60
所以這個是有點
真的是太高
有點高
那第三個就是當沖比例偏高
當沖比例偏高我一直在
查詢學術論文
我一直報告說到底
當沖比例太高會不會引起崩盤
我看到是沒有
但是問題是說
高是因為前兩年台股的當沖比例是16-27%
今年是20-30%
當沖比例是這個藍線
前兩年大概是16-27%
今年又往上提了一階
是20-30%
這個或許不會引起崩盤
但是對我們存股主而言是個困擾
怎麼樣的困擾
關你什麼事情了
對 關我有事 跟我有關
因為當沖者大部分只看價格
不看價值在做股票
所以它會造成超漲超貴的股票越漲
那我們喜歡的超跌超值的股票
越便宜
就一直趴在那裡
那是給我們造成一些困擾
對我們
那對其他人是不一定會
所以這個我也把它當成是一個挑戰
但是我奉勸大家
當這個當沖比重超過35%以上的時候
就要小心
因為在2021年真的是
有一度超過35%
然後2022年就崩盤
神奇錢還是
對 這個就
這個是我自己的觀察的角度
而且當沖的話根據統計
80%應該都賺不到錢
如果說一直在做當沖的話
我們常常看到一個震盪
就有違約交割
通常都是當沖的問題
那剛剛講到你也覺得有估值過高
當沖比率還有借貸槓桿過高的問題
那要怎麼樣來做因應
你的對策是什麼
其實那三個風險
我與其把它當成風險
其實不如把它當成挑戰
因為我很多跟我一樣
是做價值型的股票
這兩人真的很悶
然後一直很多人都抱怨說
啊好投機啊
那個
或是現在那些什麼
股票亂漲一通啊
打不過就加入他啊
富旭哥
然後就是一直抱怨
我本來也是屬於一直抱怨的
真的嗎
在去年的時候
去年我低迷的時候
但是去年第四季的時候
我就自己檢討
反省 我認為不能這樣
我覺得你一直抱怨
你一直不思改變
你就然有新的突破
所以我就想起
自己在那邊
我就想了新的一個對策
那在去年第四季的時候
我就開始做
對我的策略
大方向的策略做調整
我本來我選股票都是穩定為主
穩健 我擺第一
成長擺第二
那在去年第四季的時候
我改變了這個策略
我成長是擺第一
穩健是擺第二 把它稍微對調一下
所以我才會買傑敏KY
才會買經濟
經濟也是一樣
才會買細創
細創今天也很標啊
細創你講完之後一直上
去年底這樣吧
我才會一直加碼群立正
群聖競爭獻獲利
證獻股獲利
大概是成長不在話下
因為我做這樣的改變
我不再抱怨我做一個調整那老天爺就給我一個還不錯的return是這是我對抗風險第一個挑戰就是我現在把成長啊
我把它位階變成第一了
穩健排第二
還是要穩健
但不像以前這麼鐵齒啊
一定要很穩很穩
我覺得因為時代變了
這個市場的一個胃口也變了
你要跟著調整
這邊有講股息殖利率的要求
5%下降到4%就可以接受了
但是前提是他要成長
對
那還有第二個解放
你想要換別的國家
我做了研究
我覺得目前這個有成長
又有就是這個國家的
好像還蠻有前途的
殖利率又高的
就是我現在新加坡
巴西跟澳洲
台灣不太容易直接投資到他們吧
資金也不多
所以我現在我還沒行動
我現在只是在想法
我可能會去券商開
副委託賬戶
對 買他們的
因為台灣沒有他們掛牌的ETF
你必須要買什麼
iShare或是Vanguard這些
發行的這些單一國家ETF
那麼用副委託賬戶
或是直接去開美股賬戶也可以
去買他們的ETF
這在想還沒做
這是第二個可能的一個解方
那第三個解方就是
我本來一直都是股息為主
價差隨緣
我就是要領
領股息要成長
價差
慶菜
所以我常常就
股票就爆上爆下的
但是現在我比較
換向比較成長股
我覺得我不能再這樣
我改成股息為主 價差隨喜
有價差
你要適度了結
讓內心歡喜
這個就是隨喜的意思
所以要再停立的功夫
要更下功夫
不像以前你這樣就是
抱上抱下
有股息就好了
不行
不行這麼懶散了
像我今年就已經
就是
我已經將部分的傑敏KW
我也處分一些
群力證
因為都價差很多了
今年我連牆也賺了很多
我成本局有50幾
漲到80幾的時候
我也開始賣
風翔KY
我是因為套牢
那到1900我就解套了
也都處分掉了
遠東興 遠大金
我都有盡興部分
跟全部的獲利了結
那只要按照我以前的個性我都不會
可能都隨便
但是現在我就
會比較
注意獲利了結這件事情
可是可能每一家公司獲利了結的
原因還有比率都不一樣對不對
相機率已經賺了100多%
所以你剛剛講到的
健好就收的標準會放在哪裡
其實健好就收
有什麼用技術
隨著大盤看
或是看你的基本面
但是我今年悟出一個新法
很簡單
大家或許可以參考看看
就是回應到我才能做佑銘
就是說你不要把運氣當成你的實力
所以你要先了解你的實力在哪裡
我的實力在哪裡
對 那我傅序哥的實力就是過去14年來
我在台股的報酬率大概是16%那邊
喔 平均報酬率
對 就是有時候70幾
有時候是-6點幾
但是平均而言是大概16%
這是我的實力
每個人實力都不一樣
或許趙華實力更高
艾倫
推給艾倫
那假如我手上的部位
我現在台股的部位
我的報酬率已經超過我實力的兩倍
我是16%
32%
我就隨便賣了
我也隨便賣
我就不管
不管說什麼
再讓子彈飛一點
看什麼十日均
五日均
我不看那個
我覺得
像上半年我一度到35 36
我就賣了一些
我也不看什麼技術
我覺得那個是我運氣好
老天爺賞飯吃
我就賣一些這樣
那有沒有賣飛
沒有 有賣飛
但是沒關係
但是我沒有全
我是賣一些些
是 對
讓自己快樂開心
對啊
等一下叫富希哥請吃飯
那剛剛也有提到一件事情
就是那現在才想要來買高股CTF
好嗎
因為早上來一定想買人又變多了
對
我是建議要Hold住
Hold住嗎
對
為什麼
我先跟大家分享一個數字
高股息ETF
我看到這四檔都是我投資的
也很規模檔
56 87 899
你看他今年的漲幅
56是45.9
好多
不含配息
不含
這個
87 8是56.5
919是36.5
41.5
有沒有發現
好像2023年老AI上來的時候
高股息ETF也賺翻了
對 現在有點重演2023年的狀況
但是你要知道
他們的配息率還是很高
都是動輒9%
也有將近7%的
很高
那是因為他們拿資本利的出來配
拿賺的錢出來配
但是他們手上的持股
真正發的股息的殖利率
其實變得很低了
以0056它有公告
所以這檔是很棒的ETF
其他都不敢公告
真的喔
至少我找不到
我找了半天就找不到
001現在是4.001
我認為其他應該是跟他差不多
對啦
對 是差不多的
那以殖利率4.多
其實勉強符合我的標準
但是已經在我的標準下限了
假如它再漲個5% 6%
說實在的我就覺得太貴了
我就要賣了
所以高股息ETF 我去年
因為我去年有一陣子就是
有點迷惘
我退出了很多地保
手上現金蠻多的
我當時就對自己沒什麼信心
我買了很多高股息ETF
對
這個迷惘方向怎麼不錯
反而這個
我今年這個也賺不少
700萬這個大家也貢獻不少
但是以我目前的態度
我會Hold住
但是不會加碼所以我建議這個讓人家問我說那就看看了對 我會這麼建議那時候迷惘是覺得不要再大買個股
轉到ETF來嗎
是這個想法嗎
讓操盤人去幫你操盤
因為那時候我對我自己的選股能力
有一點有懷疑了
對 有一點懷疑
對 那不如就交給
專業的人幫我操盤好了
但是是這個想法
這邊的話
有觀眾朋友想要問你
因為很多人買高股息
反而會覺得
你拿資本利的來配
我就不用繳所得稅 二代健保
你沒有把這個當優點嗎
它這個是個優點
但這個又對我來說吸引力不大
大家為了要
所謂的一個合法的避稅
我建立你多買一些KY股
KY股每年有至少100萬的
100萬的免稅額
股息領100萬要很大的部位
好幾千萬
所以KY股 節免KY
我賺價差 股息又不用繳稅
很爽啊
對
那個整頂K1
所以我已經早就賣飛了
然後大家也不要怕繳稅
一個你這個領這麼多鼓勵
也不是你自己多厲害
這是這些公司很厲害
這個國家
這個經濟大家都很厲害 很努力
所以你領到的稅
我建議你知道
提拨20%
當作明年的繳稅基金
你不要認為你領到的稅
百分之百都是你的
領到的股息
對 領到的股息
20%是要分給別人的 國家的
要這樣想會比較好
充滿了正能量
我們每年繳稅的時候
都在那邊拗到最後一天
怨聲載道
因為剛剛講到
我們現在6月下旬了
會要進入到7月
也就是下半年了
那既然上半年獲利了結了一些部位
下半年還有沒有便宜的股票可以買
有 有有
我獲利了結 當然要直接一直
一直像馬拉松一樣一直跑
我下半年的方向
我會減碼這個漲多的減民KY
群力證
那我加碼什麼股票
我加碼最近加碼比較多的是長榮旺台
最近真的跌很凶
但是我覺得航運股今年獲利會很棒
會很砰
因為SCFI
他漲到3000點以上
現在是3000多
就是航運股的暴利區
那個賺的是暴利
那不是大賺而已
那個是暴賺
那這個效應一定遲早會出來
是
那我會加碼神機 巨錄 櫻花 東洋
這些剛好都是除息招鳥股
所以我講按照這個方向
我明年搞不好上半年
我領的股息就
就很澎湃
現在已經在想明年上半年了
對
那我會提高我的現金部位
但是我又不喜歡
這活存沒有股力
所以我現在也開始買了
那個公司在ETF
跟飛投資在ETF
當作我的現金部位
那我甚至考慮
我今年大概可以領
140幾萬的股息
我打算拿部分去降低槓桿
因為最近大家見證的態度
我看自己都有點怕
那我自己也有
你是什麼剛剛
我是用房子去增大
對
還有大概300萬
所以現在還有啊
還有還有 對
我借了450
那現在大概還有300
然後打算說今年領一些鼓勵
部分的鼓勵來還
降低剛剛
也是讓自己更安心
下半年的布局 對
好 可是今年不會降息囉
那還要買債嗎
這個我不在乎
因為債對我而言就是
資金
parking在那邊而已
那我要用的時候
他或許 帳面損失1、2%
我不太在乎的啦
你做股票的
你的利息3、4%
你都敢借了
在意說
暫損有1、2%
不會在意的啦
其實現在殖利率
反而是相對穩定
反而卡在這邊
剛剛講到還有一些
便宜的股票
這個要很有耐性吧 神機
神機
今年真的好慘
今年跌了14.5%
我們大盤漲了快50%
真的好慘
嚴重天息
他有很糟嗎
沒有
他營收連續第12年創新高
今年應該會再創歷史新高
沒有很差
很穩健
只是第一年的獲利
第一季的獲利是衰退12%
讓大家有點擔心
但是我覺得這個擔心
有點把它太過分了
殺到這個程度
最近百年
但是我覺得他 我認為他很有前景
他可能是下一個傑敏K1
真的假啊
是下一個傑敏K1
為什麼 他的產業不一樣
他是做軍工強固型電腦
那現在不是有AIPC嗎
我看AIPC換機槽
AIPC很貴 一台要十幾萬
但是軍工一台也要一二十萬
軍方一定會馬上換AIPC
因為這跟國防安全有關
你個人沒有用AIPC頂多被笑你落伍
這是一個國家安全
俄羅斯有AIPC
美國一定要換
這跟戰力國力有關
所以我認為後年的換基潮
基本上會相當的激烈
超低本益比
質地率6%以上
好難找到這樣的東西
這個紀錄今年也是一樣
它是最近大跌
大跌快10%
貼息嗎
貼息
對 那原因不明
五月營收有稍微差一點
但是也上半年有一點弱
但是還是繼續成長
那因為他是標案的
他那個工程
按照公司要怎樣把下半年
才會入戰
所以我覺得他被挫殺了
而且他還是那個所謂的台積電的
那個供應鏈概念股
而且最近
摩根史丹利說
亞洲將迎來超級工業資本支出的循環
它是最大的收費股
它收費不會像
不會一下子
但是是細水長流的
這個就很適合存股主
還是找得到適合存股的好標的
今天真的很謝謝傅旭哥
也很開心聽到傅旭哥
上半年現在聽起來
已經一掃去年的陰霾
也勉勵大家如果自己的持股
有點在逆風的時候
不要抱怨是來想對策
因為有微調
就是把成長這件事情放在比較前面
那下半年其實他們
你也評估過他們下半年是會成長的
對不對
聚入跟生計
那像櫻花呢